the way that we were positioned in like
cuddling with one another and the high
schooler's someone came up and said
that's backwards he's supposed to be
doing that to you and I think that was
just like my name is EC Joe Lopez I'm 32
I am 5-2 and currently single I'm
Samantha I'm 31 years old I'm six foot
four and recently single how do I feel
about my height well right now I'm okay
with it
but when I was younger I really really
hated it there's times even now that I
wish I was taller I mean everybody wants
to be taller I pretty much like my
Heights there definitely are some days
where it's a little bit more difficult
but in general I have women that always
come up to me complimenting me on my
Heights complete strangers I'm six foot
four and it's a struggle for online
dating I think a lot of guys just don't
even want to go they're like nope she's
taller than me I won't even think about
it
[Music]
I have the same struggle with online if
I put a 5 - nobody wants to like you
know swipe right so I have a little
difficult with that I usually don't get
matches and when I do get a match like I
like like messaging back and they just
disappear me from I get a lot more of
the weird like fetish she literally
getting asked if I can send pictures of
my feet because I'm so tall obviously I
have big feet you know literally been
asked like I'll pay you money okay not
that broke this month I think in person
my personality comes out more and in
real life it's like oh that's not that
much of a difference I don't really
notice it as much in real life I have a
little trouble as well what I try to do
is try to put my personality at the same
level so like if I'm short i'ma try to
you know beat it with my personality but
I do like think that it affects me and I
think girls do actually like feel more
physically attracted to like a taller
guy I definitely think that that shorter
men have it harder when it comes to
dating even though I feel like people
perceive me as more dominant or
masculine
I think that's easy for me to overcome
with how I dress and if you're trying to
like overcome your masculinity you come
off as a douchebag you just have to be
yourself a common struggle that I have
with just dating in general is guys
assume that because I'm so tall that I'm
like rough and tough I definitely gets a
little bit frustrating walking me home
at the end of the night like if we're in
the neighborhood it's like oh you're
fine you're six foot four you might be
right but I still want to feel like a
lady I still want you know like them to
make help me feel protected and I don't
get that a lot and I feel like I
probably overcompensate with how girly I
talk or dress to really make it like I'm
feminine with me totally the opposite or
they see me lacy like oh he's like 5
foot he's what he's gonna do he's gonna
protect me you know
I do think Heights standards
reinforce gender roles because it's this
like physical embodiment of the woman is
the damsel and the man is the
breadwinner I would actually get that
comment a lot of oh who wears the pants
here or like an even in my last
relationship we were the same heights
we were both six foot four but it was
still nope this is this is backward I
went to a bar with my friend and there
was this girl right there and I went to
talk to her and like she pushed me like
she physically pushed me she's like are
you too small for me and like I was like
oh okay it really like affected me like
I usually don't let things affect me you
know like it really hurt like hurt me so
I just like walked away on a constant
basis if I'm walking down the street I
get called at a common phrase from I
don't even know middle school on is damn
she's a huge yeah yeah yelling it in a
car driving past walking on the other
side of the street that's not obviously
rejection because I'm not trying to date
that up but still it definitely sits
with you like yeah it does like
sometimes like I'm walking I could hear
like comments like I said I'm passing by
like oh he's short or something you know
a little something I'm like oh okay I
just don't pay attention but I was like
oh I heard it and I'm like damn
it makes me question myself like oh did
I do something wrong like you know and
then you're like oh maybe it's because
like my height I think the same as well
I would love for people to see past my
heights my empathy my caring Ness I
would just like for the missing Who I am
like very lovable very giving cares
about people I feel that I don't get
that opportunity that often I think
height standards are maybe not
necessarily healthy if there's a strict
adherence to these standards this is
what I need understanding that you're
attracted to a certain type of person
though mm-hmm that is healthy as long as
you're not making other people who are
outside of that attraction feel bad
about themselves they might not be
healthy but I think it's just natural it
just like everybody has that everybody
that date's is gonna be dealing with a
certain issue within themselves mine
just happens to be my height
you